I'm back back in New York
[Music]
lissa
Berlin this is Naomi is my wife Alyssa
and her sister Gwen how many assistants
is this make Nick I'm sorry she makes my
life miserable my mom called one of her
oldest friends from college is kid just
moved here I met the girl once and she
was something like five sure she sucks
now thank you for showing up like that
may other people claim round for my
company is your wife Clem oh she does
not claim
it makes been a bad boy it took them
years to find a path back to being
normal ish I think people never make
films about ordinary people who don't
really do anything they're out there I
can take it up
do I need to I'm worried about Naomi
[Music]
let's just let this whole affair be
simple affair what Roy same word
my sister-in-law she's duplicitous she's
a liar this gossip you know talking
about someone as soon as they leave the
room kind of makes me feel ill why his
buddy coming back he's gonna be out a
little while you sure he's not out with
what's-her-face why would you say that
would you tell me if you thought he only
was untrustworthy Naomi's not the
problem is there a problem I had like
the most difficult part about being as
transient as I have been is how
vulnerable I am to infatuation but when
you place then I meet somebody and I
fall in love with him and then I just
won't want to leave
I wonder if the next time we see each
other we'll have met someone who makes
us feel or desire that's a novel concept
you